Here's one last simplification that I want to show you. Again, there's multiple
ways to do that type of problem. So, I'm going to show you two, and you choose
what you prefer. In the first way, I'm going to start outside the parenthesis
and take care of this negative exponent. I do the reciprocal of the entire
inside parenthesis to get 1 over 3a to the 4th, b to the negative 3 squared.
Next, I square each factor in the parenthesis. 1 squared is 1. 3 squared is 9. A
to the 4th squared is a to the 8th. And b to the negative 3 squared is b to the
negative 6. Finally, we move b to the negative 6 to the numerator for our final
result. The second way of doing this problem is starting inside the parentheses.
We can move any negative exponents to the denominator. So I have 3a to the 4th
divided by b cubed, and then all of this is raised to the negative 2. We have a
fraction that's a base raised to a negative exponent. So we take the reciprocal
of this entire fraction and change the exponent to be positive. Finally, b cubed
squared is b to the 6, 3 squared is 9, and a to the 4 squared is a to the 8th.
Here's our anwer. Both of these results are the same. So we know our work is
correct. In the first case, i started with a negative exponent here. Then I
handled the negative exponent on the inside. For the second case, I handled this
negative exponent on the inside first, then I did the negative exponent on the
outside. You'll have to move terms around either way you do it, just get
comfortable with one way.